the jurogan experience mental toughness
is one of the most important aspects of
wrestling obviously technique and
fitness are huge
but mental toughness is what defines
wrestlers in my opinion because
when you see wrestlers successful
wrestlers in my in
you know the ufc in particular there's
no one like them
when when they come over to mma you you
recognize like there's
there's something special about them as
athletes
and i think that it comes from the fact
that wrestling is
so difficult the practices are so hard
but in the world of mental toughness
where mental toughness is
one of the cornerstones you're known as
a guy
that stands out like you stand out
amongst like
like david goggins likes to say you're
uncommon
amongst uncommon men like what what is
that like what
what what made you stand out from these
other wrestlers
well i'm going to jump forth to my high
school coach
even though i got a lot before that but
almost i just remember what he said in
the room
and he was like the best high school
coach in the state at the time
he said guys win
with humility
lose with dignity but damn it don't lose
[Laughter]
and he he put those last two lines
together real quick so he kind of had to
listen to him but you know it's pretty
neat because you win with humility you
lose with dignity but
damn it don't lose and so you know it's
it it
that was my first major coach that
really taught me
a lot of those type of principles but
before that i was i was a kid that
was at the ymca when i was five six
years old and
and basically the reason why i was there
because you know you want to learn how
to swim because
if you're a outdoors guy and you want to
be around water and you want to you want
to make sure you know how your kids swim
so my mom and dad got me at the ymca but
what they got me into the ymca really
for was
they needed help i mean they just my dad
was a full-time
worker and my mom she stayed at home a
lot but she also helped my dad at
office at home but i was a little
hellion
and they needed me to learn how to swim
but they also needed me to
learn how to be a little bit sociable
they needed me to learn how to
to get along with kids my first job was
at the ymca
i actually competed my first sport
competitively was
besides practicing was swimming and i
won a ymca state championship when i was
12 years old believe it or not
in the back stroke which you know in
wrestling
you know i know in fighting you can go
to your back and there's lots of tools
that you can do there
but i hate going to my back you know and
i think if i was a fighter
i don't i would think i hate gravity
coming down on me
so i don't mind putting it down but you
know there's skills there you have to
learn
but i am i really um i really liked
the ymca because it gave me
a chance to learn something away from
home i was home with my mom it's home
with my dad home with my sister
four years older than me but you know
it's it's just something i call it
going for help and i think my mom and
dad realized
at that time that they needed some help
with this kid
and i think that's a really good thing
to think about as
as people in the world when you have
kids growing up
and if you're not giving them what you
need to give them
why not go for help and there's
organizations out there now you got to
be careful
you know who you're putting them into or
even if you give them to a babysitter or
whatever like that but
you know if you if you're if you're
pretty confident that you
have a good place to get some help you
get some help and i
and i the same way of me as a coach same
with me as a husband
i mean i got my wife i got my family
i got i had my assistant coaches and i i
got my
fans i mean i got i always had them
looking out for me i built that kind of
trust with them
or more than even trust just they want
to help
and that was the way now you can't go
overboard you still got to
make sure that the help you're getting
is the right help
but the ymca was perfect for me because
uh
i mean i can remember the first day they
took us to a wrestling room we had a
little wrestling room at the ymca
and i was already wrestling before that
because my dad was a
wrestler not a great wrestler but his
friends were so when they when they came
to wrestling
learning to sport my first wrestling
room was at the ymca there
even though i had been in a wrestling
room because these older guys had
drugged me around into the wrestling
rooms but
in waterloo but i can remember russ and
a kid
and i i handled him pretty good because
i had already been wrestled in my carpet
at home
rustling outside in the grass and and
these people had had a had a little
experience with me
so but the kid you know kind of got mad
so i was waiting for my mom and dad
to uh uh pick me up after the uh
the one after the wise couple hours
where he you spend there
and this kid came out and he goes you
know you can
you know maybe you beat me and wrestling
up there but he goes uh
how about a street fight and i said whoa
you know i was probably eight nine
eight years old at the time and you know
i
it was was downtown waterloo iowa tough
town
i was on one side of the river and he
was on the other side of the river
growing up and and so he probably had
been in more
fights than me but
i didn't wasn't gonna really i wasn't
gonna fight him
i was waiting for my dad picked me up
and all of a sudden
he punches me and
so you know what do you do you got to
fight i mean either run
you know and i i fought and i did all
right
i mean just like in the wrestling room i
did all right and so i was i had i had
some of that in me too
but when i was i had the guy on the down
and i kind of let him up
we both looked over my dad was there
standing watching me and that guy's dad
was standing there and my mom
my dad and his were talking to each
other and so you know that's
part of experience that you kind of grew
up in
and i don't know if they even knew each
other but they were kind of supervising
yet we didn't know they were there right
and that was kind of one of my first
experiences
with understanding a little bit about
uh competition outside the organized
sports
you know yeah raw competition right yeah
yeah
primal yep yeah so you know
actually speaking of the story there it
was a really good one
uh this is about my mom and dad my mom
and dad were great people
but they like to drink a lot of beer and
smoke a lot of cigarettes and
that's why they probably didn't live so
long and they probably
had a lot of had some trouble at home
and by that i mean the cops visited a
home quite often
just to break up fights or my
mom would probably call the cops on my
dad and
so the first time i ever really
took notice was when they came the first
time and they
took my dad away and you know
he had been rough with my mom so i
probably understood but i saw him kind
of
throw a handcuff on him they just i
think they just threw one on and kind of
took him out the door i didn't really
see from there
so
he came home that night later on he got
he was did he just
you know i don't think i brought him
back later but
so the next day i went to school and
the cop that had the policeman that had
come and picked him up
was actually a neighbor down the street
just live about a block from us and
i was really bad you know at the police
taking my dad away even though probably
it was a good thing
but i didn't really understand what was
going on at that time this and this is
different
today probably wouldn't go on but
the neighbor policeman about a block
away
had a son in my class at school so
after school that day
i we were both walking home
and i was really mad and i pulled out of
my pocket
a wire
and i took this kid down on the ground
and i wired his wrists together
and not real hard but like like there
were handcuffs and i
grabbed the wire and i said this is what
your dad did to my dad last night
and i'm gonna do it to you and i'm gonna
take you and i'm gonna take you home
this way
and i took him home because they lived
about a block away and ian took the
things off and let him go in
but it's like probably
fourth grade but
my dad found out about that and wow what
did i get in trouble
i mean he used to hit me on top of the
head with a ring probably why i don't
have much hair but
but um and uh and he looked at me
and he he said you know what i was
intoxicated last night it was good they
took me out of here
but you know what they did to me when i
got me down to the police department
he said i played pool with them they had
a little billiards room down there
and they played pool with me until i
sobered up and then they brought me back
and uh and you did that to his son i
said dad
i i i was just protecting
you i thought you know but and everybody
understood but
it's kind of funny how things are and i
don't think that's the old days
good old days uh compared to i don't
you know they'd probably do a lot more
you know they'd lock you up probably but
i don't give them too many breaks but uh
it's kind of funny how
that's the kind of house you know the
difference between 40 years ago
50 years ago 60 years ago what do you
think is better though
like the good are the good old days the
good old days is better today
i think i like the good old days
i mean i got picked up one other time
and it was my uh
former uh i was back home and from
college
and and he um
he was my gym teacher in eighth grade
and uh mr blue and
he uh he ended up being a policeman
so when i came home college so that was
about in seventh grade
so we're talking six seven and eight
years later
when i was home for the weekend and and
i was driving and
he picked me up and i probably had a
beer in the car or something
you know he he actually um let me go
but he picked me up again the same night
so he took me down a second time and he
put me in his office in the police
station and we talked for quite a while
but let me go too but you know
you just can't get away with it i mean
there's just more rules regulations and
if people find out it's like
whoa whoa you know i think the good old
days probably gave you a chance to
actually realize things better than you
can today
you can actually get a second chance
maybe
and you know that type of thing catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience